Here are the factored pairs for negative 45 and we want to find one that sums to
four. Well, negative 5 and 9 multiply to negative 45 and add to 4, so these are
my answers for the first number puzzle. For the second number puzzle, I want to
find 2 numbers that multiply to negative 45 and add to negative 12. That must be
3 and negative 15. For the third number puzzle, I want to find factors of 45
that sum to negative 14. Well, here are the positive factor pairs for positive
45, but none of these pairs add to negative 14. This must mean I need the
negative factor pairs of positive 45. We know a negative times a negative is a
positive. So now, I'm just looking for the factor pair that adds to negative 14.
This would be negative 5 and negative 9. This must mean the last factor pair is
negative 1 and negative 45. They sum to negative 46 and they multiply to
positive 45.